nice to meet you all right this is
what's going on with Megan I'm a psychic
medium and a tarot card reader here in
LA I think I got powers too
I think you do too I can take a bus
somebody write and talk to two or three
years and I run into em hmm
I think I'm full blown thank you
straight up yeah I have dreams
why are you the more upper echelon of
the tarot reading or the psychic reason
so what makes me different from other
readers is that I'm actually tuned in
I'm actually talking to spear guides I'm
getting more specific for people don't
be scared I'm scared because I'm saging
here I just want to make sure when you
say it we need hey sometimes to Sage
when it starts to feel heavy or needs
some clearing before I do a reading sage
is just like it raises the vibration and
it clears out any negative energy that's
kind of what this does exactly yeah I
kind of wheels out Oh kind of a negative
energy
there's medicine both of them are you
ready girl yeah let's see what we've got
here I love that Wow
okay so first thing I'm getting is like
you're really changing your way of
thinking right now you've got you as the
Sun the Sun is like really it's just
pure positivity you also had your very
grounded - I'm seeing I'm roots into the
ground
it's your grounded person for a very
creative person do you sing I'm getting
singer with you - like very talented
singer beautiful singer I see a lot of
men trying to own you and I feel like
they tried - so how much does this cost
well I have different scales for like
this one would be like for 30 minutes to
be 150 which is my lowest it's my
starting so this is the thing for the 30
minutes when does the 30 minutes start
doesn't start we once the cars get
flipped or once you walk in or because
it's a foreplay of some foreplay before
we started this it was it was a lot of
you just trying to get to know the
person which kind of in my personal
opinion helped you read them a little
better because we just things has come
in and it shuffles
so it's kind of like you do like an
interviewing process to try to shake
really most people it's like hello nice
to meet you come in we sit down let me
start you know this is my first time
ever ever being a part of a reading you
know I don't know what I'm getting with
you so I don't want to read you too much
because I know you're freaks you up it
I'm getting that you're gonna get a lot
of music video ideas and visual stuff
and your dreams that have to do with
your art we got to make sure you get
enough sleep so you can get some of
those images and ideas
I'm excited whatever okay no see yeah
I'm trying to play the game zone cuz
when I saw her our videos is dope and
she need to see one of my videos to see
what to do a song oh you come in here
you like you need to sleep more so you
can shoot a video so I mean okay I sleep
a lot and I have a lot of adduced she's
got the visions I got my reading for the
day there you go it's all you need it
you get what you need when you need it
not going I like surprises that's just
me Junaid she looks like a psycho
she likes he owns a crystal ball but
salute Megan for what she does for a
living
said she has a lot of weight lifters on
her tab so I can respect that and she's
very multi-talented she told me she
sings tumbling she freestyles told me
she's an actress and she reads palms so
I mean what the [ __ ]
she's almost not Jamaican or some [ __ ]
shot the Megan keep doing what you're
doing
oh no this is not my cup of tea I don't
see that in my future